SO IT'S UP TO US
TO PICK UP THE SLACK, OKAY?
[door closes]
- UM, HELLO?
- YEAH.
MAY I HELP YOU?
- UM, I'M DENISE.
- YEAH, MY NAME IS LIZ.
I'M PART OF PUBLIZITY.
IT'S BASED OFF OUR NAMES.
- UH...
DO YOU KNOW
WHERE MY AUNT ELIZABETH IS?
- OKAY, YOU GUYS, GET
THE [bleep] OUT OF HERE, OKAY?
HI, SWEETHEART.
- UM, I'M MY AUNT ELIZABETH'S
NIECE DENISE.
AND...
WHAT THE HECK?
- THAT'S CASSANDRA.
YOU DON'T HAVE
TO PAY ATTENTION TO HER, OKAY?
SO YOU CAME HERE TO SEE
YOUR AUNT ELIZABETH.
- EXACTLY. MY AUNT ELIZABETH
INVITED ME TO COME
AND VISIT HER,
AND SO I DID.
AND SHE SENT ME
IN A LIMOUSINE FROM THE AIRPORT.
I FEEL LIKE I SHOULD CALL
MY PARENTS AND TELL THEM THAT...
[breathes deeply]
MY AUNT ELIZABETH
DIDN'T COME AFTER THE LIMO.
- YOUR PARENTS TALK
ABOUT YOUR AUNT ELIZABETH?
- THEY SAY THAT SHE'S
A PIECE-OF-TRASH PERSON.
- YOU'RE FUNNY.
I LIKE YOU.
YOU'RE BASICALLY THE LARGEST
WOMAN I'VE EVER SEEN.
- OH, MY GOD, THANK YOU.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
- MAYBE WE SHOULD, LIKE,
GO OUT TO LUNCH
AND JUST HAVE,
LIKE, GIRL TALK.
- IS THIS A TRICK?
- LOOK, YOU HAVE THIS SWEET,
LOST LITTLE GIRL.
IT'S, LIKE, MY MOTHERING
INSTINCTS JUST, LIKE...
[deep voice]
KICK IN.
[upbeat music]
♪
AND, LIKE, NOW
I JUST, LIKE, WANT TO EAT SALAD.
IT'S, LIKE, CRAZY.
IT'S, LIKE,
THAT'S WHAT I'M CRAVING.
SO, LIKE, THAT'S
WHAT I'M HAVING FOR LUNCH.
- NICE SHOES.
I LIKE THOSE.
- OH, YOU LIKE THEM?
- YEAH, THEY'RE GREAT.
- YEAH, WE GOT 'EM
ON A SHOPPING SPREE TODAY.
- IT'S AMAZING
WHAT YOU CAN GET SHOPPING.
- WAIT.
HOLD ON ONE SECOND.
ARE YOU A PHOTOGRAPHER?
- YEAH.
- WELL, THIS IS DENISE.
SHE'S VISITING.
- HI.
- HEY.
- OH, MY GOD.
I JUST HAD AN AMAZING IDEA.
THERE'S, LIKE,
CRAZY ARTISTIC CHEMISTRY
HAPPENING HERE.
[camera shutter clicking]
WOULD YOU BE INTERESTED IN DOING
A PHOTO SHOOT WITH DENISE
SO SHE CAN GET, LIKE,
SOME HEAD SHOTS AND STUFF?
- WHAT DO YOU THINK?
I MEAN, OF COURSE I WANT
TO TAKE PICTURES OF HER.
- AM I BEING DISCOVERED
RIGHT NOW?
AND IF SO, CAN YOU PLEASE TAKE
MY PICTURE
BY A COCONUT PALM TREE?
- I CAN TAKE YOUR PICTURE
NEXT TO JUST ABOUT ANYTHING.
LET'S START RIGHT NOW.
[cell phone buzzing]
- OKAY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I JUST HAVE TO TAKE THIS CALL.
YOU GUYS SIT DOWN
AND FIGURE IT OUT.
NO, JUST DO IT.
I GOT TO TAKE THIS.
- WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
- HELLO? NO, CASSANDRA!
YOU'RE BEING A [bleep] IDIOT!
- LIZ!
LIZ.
OH, WE'RE STARTING?
[camera shutter clicks]
CAN I SEE?
- OH, THESE ARE GREAT.
[camera shutter clicks]
- CAN I SEE IT?
MAY I PLEASE SEE IT?
[camera shutter clicks]
OH, THAT WAS A WINK.
- OH, MY GOD,
I SEE MAGAZINE COVERS HERE.
- REALLY?
DO YOU KNOW WHERE LIZ WENT?
- WHO'S LIZ?
- LIZ IS MY...
[camera shutter clicks]
LIZ IS MY...
[camera shutter clicking]
- YOU'RE MY NIECE NOW.